dans certaines villes les prix baissent
alors qu'est ce qui les fait baisser ses
prix bas les gens partent vers les
villes dans laquelle son atoll vous
savez fondamentalement si on considère
le marché privé
c'est un marché effectivement c'est le
rapport entre l'offre et la demande qui
fait kiffer et qui fait les prix doux
sans aucun doute l'importance aussi
d'avoir un marché à voir du logement
social pour justement sortir de cette
logique folle qui fait que désormais
voilà des délais classes moyennes
n'arrive plus à se loger un dans dans
l'est dans les métropoles et c'est
vraiment pour ça que la relance de la
production logement social est
absolument déterminante
et n'oublions jamais logement social
c'est pas des logements pour les pauvres
ces logements qui est accessible
théoriquement pratiquement les deux
tiers des ménages des ménages français
si on n'arrive pas à relancer ça en tout
cas dans l'est dans les métropoles et
dans les zones tendues
la sous réserve donc on arrive à moi
qu'on arrive à mettre en place des
mécanismes d'encadrement des loyers
quand bien même on le ferait on sait
bien travay avoir des effets sur la
réduction la production de ces de ses
loyers privés et dont on reporte aussi à
moyen terme la crise donc en l'état
actuel la seule solution qu'ont qu'on
aime et c'est même pas une solution de
court terme c'est la production de
logement social et puis à plus long
terme s'est aussi posé une question sur
des politiques d'aménagement du
territoire parce que pourquoi est ce cas
de tel décalage entre l'offre et la
demande dans les métropoles c'est parce
que on assiste à un grand mouvement
depuis une trentaine d'années une
vingtaine d'années d'afflux dans ces
territoires de concentration de
popularisation de la population dans ces
territoires territoires qui sont déjà
dans son peut pas produire à l'infini en
ile de france
on peut pas produire l'infini à nantes à
rennes à nice etc et donc se pose
aujourd'hui la question de bad et des
politiques on peut avoir bien au delà
des politiques du logement pour
organiser un aménagement du territoire
qui va permettre d'avoir d'autres formes
de développement que le développement
purement metropolit